Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. On the 18th of May 1922, the British translator and novelist Sidney Schiff hosted a dinner party at the Majestic Hotel in Paris. Forty guests were invited in all, but there were four guests in particular that Schiff wanted to bring together to generate, to see sharing dinner party chat. They were Igor Stravinsky, the great Russian composer, Pablo Picasso, great Cubist painter, James Joyce, Marcel Proust, probably the two greatest novelists of the 20th century. Stravinsky and Picasso turn up on time, but Joyce and Proust don't.
感谢收听《历史的剩余》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1922年5月18日，英国翻译家兼小说家西德尼·希夫在巴黎大酒店举办了一场晚宴。总共邀请了四十位客人，但希夫特别想把其中四位客人聚在一起，以此来制造、看看他们分享晚宴聊天的场景。他们是伊戈尔·斯特拉文斯基，伟大的俄罗斯作曲家；巴勃罗·毕加索，伟大的立体主义画家；詹姆斯·乔伊斯和马塞尔·普鲁斯特，这可能是20世纪最伟大的两位小说家。斯特拉文斯基和毕加索按时到了，但乔伊斯和普鲁斯特没有来。
And then very late, Joyce turns up and he is very shabbily dressed and he's drunk. Yeah, he's drunk. And he's got drunk because he doesn't have evening wear. And so he's a bit stressed about that so which is a of i mean we've all we've all been in that situation this is what you've got to wear you and your deck shoes again isn't it exactly so you just get drunk and then you turn up and anyway but then in contrast to joyce he's all kind of disheveled and shabby, Proust turns up at 2.30, immaculately dressed, kind of beautiful buttonhole, white gloves.
然后很晚的时候，乔伊斯来了，他衣衫褴褛，而且喝醉了。对，他喝醉了。他喝醉是因为他没有晚礼服。所以他对此有点压力，这也就是说——我的意思是，我们都经历过那种情况，这就是你得穿的衣服，你又穿上你的船鞋了，对吧？——完全正确，所以你只是喝醉了，然后你出现了。不管怎样，但与乔伊斯形成鲜明对比的是，他显得有些蓬头垢面、衣衫褴褛，普鲁斯特在两点半才到，衣着一丝不苟，胸前挂着漂亮的插花，戴着白手套。
You'd expect that. White silk scarf. And they settle down. And their conversation, the conversation between Joyce and Proust, the two greatest novelists of the 20th century, it's not – Well, there are different versions of it. It doesn't sing, does it? There are different versions. So one of them is that uh proust they they basically are only thought to
你会料到会这样。白色的丝绸围巾。他们安顿下来。他们的对话，乔伊斯和普鲁斯特之间的对话，这两位20世纪最伟大、最杰出的小说家，并不是——好吧，关于这件事有不同的版本。它并不出彩，对吧？有不同的版本。所以其中一种说法是，呃，普鲁斯特，他们基本上被认为只
have exchanged a few words and some people say that proust said to joyce do you like truffles and uh i'm not gonna do joyce's accent a terrible accent joyce said i can't joy said yes i do that's brilliant liam neeson yeah that was the reason that we mentioned this obviously is that it's the 100th anniversary not just of that meeting but of dominant you i mean you suggested this that this that this is the year the modern begins and um it the the person actually who suggested that 1922 was a kind of year zero well actually 1921 is a year zero so 1922 is is year one yeah um was uh ezra pound uh notorious subsequently as a kind of fascist uh supporter of mussolini he went to prison didn't he I mean he got convicted in the long run yes but in his early incarnation was an incredible patron of um kind of radically brilliant writers so not just Joyce but also T.S. Eliot so uh which is and Eliot's great poem
交换了几句话，有些人说普鲁斯特对乔伊斯说：你喜欢松露吗？呃，我不会模仿乔伊斯的口音，那是个糟糕的口音。乔伊斯说，我不能——乔伊斯说：是的，我喜欢。这太棒了，利亚姆·尼森。是的，我们提到这件事的原因显然是，今年不仅是那次会面的100周年，也是多米尼克，我的意思是，是你建议的，这——这——这是现代开端的一年。呃，实际上建议1922年是某种零年的人——其实1921年才是零年，所以1922年是一年级，对吧，呃——是埃兹拉·庞德，后来作为墨索里尼的某种法西斯支持者而臭名昭著。他入狱了，不是吗？我的意思是，他最终被定罪了，是的。但在他早期的化身中，他是某种激进才华横溢的作家的不可思议的赞助人，不仅是乔伊斯，还有T·S·艾略特，所以——而且艾略特的伟大诗作
The Wasteland is also published in 1922 so Ezra Pound is kind of moving around in the background here. And he wrote to H.L. Mencken, who was the guy who covered the monkey trial in America, Scope's trial. And he said, the Christian era ended at midnight on October the 29th to the 30th of last year, i.e. 1921. You are now in the year 1 PSU,
《荒原》也是在1922年出版的，所以埃兹拉·庞德在背景中四处活动。他写信给H·L·门肯，就是那个在美洲报道猴子审判、斯科普斯审判的人。他说：“基督教时代结束于去年10月29日至30日的午夜，即1921年。你现在处于公元后尤利西斯元年（PSU），”
post scriptum ulysses, if that is any comfort to you uh and i wonder uh do you think pound was onto something is 1922 well we had lots of questions about this tom when we put it out so lauren mgm for example said why 1922 is it a spectacularly loaded year just due to a cluster of important events um and i think there is something about 1922 so there are particular years aren't there that feel you know resonant 1968 1989 um particularly in the sort of immediate aftermath and i think 1922 if to me it feels like the the great war and the great War is completely going to overshadow this episode
如果这能给你带来任何安慰的话。呃，我想，你觉得庞德说得对吗？1922年是——当我们将这个话题抛出时，我们收到了很多关于这方面的提问，汤姆，例如劳伦·MGM说：为什么是1922年？仅仅因为一堆重要事件的聚集，它就是一个备受瞩目的年份吗？我觉得1922年确实有些特别之处，有些年份就是会让人觉得（你知道的）充满共鸣，比如1968年、1989年，尤其是在事件发生的紧随其后的一段时间里。我觉得，对我来说，1922年感觉就像是一场大战，而第一次世界大战将完全笼罩这一期节目，
as it overshadowed all culture and politics at the time. The Great War had been this tremendous rupture. And then people think that the war ended and then the Roaring Twenties began. That's the way it's commonly presented in the popular imagination. But it's not really like that at all. The war doesn't end definitively because lots of fighting continues in 1919 1920 and so on yeah as well i mean the russian civil war fighting in turkey and so on irish civil war irish civil war incredibly brutal and bloody so the war doesn't
就像它当时笼罩了所有的文化和政治一样。第一次世界大战曾是一次巨大的裂变。然后人们认为战争结束了，接着“咆哮的二十年代”就开始了。大众想象中通常是这样呈现的。但实际情况根本不是这样的。战争并没有就此彻底结束，因为许多战斗在1919年、1920年及以后仍在继续，是的，还有——我的意思是，俄罗斯内战、土耳其境内的战斗等等，爱尔兰内战，爱尔兰内战极其残酷和血腥，所以战争并没有
really end and there's this period of two or three years of tremendous flux and uncertainty and i think 1922 feels like the point at which things begin to settle down a bit and a new order is sort of palpable and new themes that are going to dominate the politics. Actually, in the case of one of these themes, which is Bolshevism and the existence of the USSR, that's,
真正结束。随后迎来了两三年的巨大动荡和不确定性时期，我认为1922年感觉像是局势开始稍微稳定下来的时间点，一种新的秩序隐约可见，将主导政治的新主题也浮出水面。事实上，其中一个主题是布尔什维克主义和苏联的存在，那是——
I mean, the USSR is only comes into being at the end of 1922, but that's not just going to dominate the politics of the USSR, that's, I mean, the USSR only comes into being at the end of 1922. But that's not just going to dominate the politics of the 1920s. It's going to dominate politics right through to the end of the 1980s. And I think you can see, argue there is a block of history from the early 1920s right through to, let's say, the end of the 1980s that is dominated. I mean, the issue of communism versus capitalism is absolutely central to it, but also the disintegration of the great empires
我的意思是，苏联直到1922年底才正式诞生，但这不仅将主导20世纪的政治——我的意思是，苏联直到1922年底才正式诞生。但这不仅将主导20世纪20年代的政治。它将主导政治一直持续到20世纪80年代末。我想你可以看到，或者说可以认为，存在着一个历史板块，从20世纪20年代初一直延续到——比方说——20世纪80年代末，都是由它主导的。我的意思是，共产主义对资本主义这个议题绝对是其中的核心，还有伟大帝国的解体，
and what is going to happen to the world in the wake of these European colonial empires. Yes. You could also say about other things as well. So relationship of the United Kingdom and Ireland. Yes. Dated 1922, really. The configuration of what we'd call the Middle East,
以及这些欧洲殖民帝国瓦解之后世界将走向何方。是的。你也可以对其他事情这么说。比如联合王国和爱尔兰的关系。是的。实际上可以追溯到1922年。我们称之为中东的地区的格局，
but then would have been known as the Levant. Yeah. Takes on, you know, things develop in 1922. But I wonder if we're talking specifically about, you know, 1922 as the year that the modern begins. Yeah. There are obviously that the events that we're begins. Yeah. They're obviously that the events that we're talking about now
但在当时被称为黎凡特。是的。开始成形，（你知道的）事情在1922年发展起来。但我想知道，如果我们具体谈论（你知道的）1922年作为现代开始的一年。是的。显然，我们现在谈论的那些事件
are political ones. And you could say 1914 would be a more obvious one or 1917 for the Russian Revolution or 1918, the end of the First World War. But we began with Picasso and Stravinsky and Joyce and Proust. And there is also this idea that around this time,
是政治事件。你可以说1914年是一个更明显的年份，或者1917年代表俄国革命，或者1918年第一次世界大战的结束。但我们是从毕加索、斯特拉文斯基、乔伊斯和普鲁斯特开始的。并且还有这样一种观点，即在大约这个时候，
culturally, things change. And that 1922 could rank there with, I don't know, Freud or Picasso or whatever. But I think the reason for this year, particularly if you're English speaking, is that the greatest English novel in English and the greatest poem in English written in the 20th century, both published in the same year. And they're both texts that cast themselves as kind of modern. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right.
在文化上，事情发生了变化。1922年可以与——我不知道——弗洛伊德、毕加索或其他什么人并列。但我认为这一年之所以特殊，特别是如果你说英语的话，是因为英语世界最伟大的英文小说和20世纪写就的最伟大的英文长诗，都在同一年出版。而且这两部文本都将自己塑造为某种现代的作品。是的，我认为这绝对是对的。
And indeed, in a way, kind of a breaking down of the tradition that had gone before. I think that's absolutely right. It's the end of Victorianism, isn't it? I mean, we can argue the modern and modernism are very, very slippery concepts. Thomas Hardy talks about the ache of modernism in Tess of the d'Urbervilles, written decades before. And you can see modernist fiction, modernist culture emerging before the First World War.
而且事实上，在某种程度上，它打破了之前的传统。我认为这绝对是对的。这是维多利亚主义的终结，不是吗？我的意思是，我们可以争论“现代”和“现代主义”是非常非常难以捉摸的概念。托马斯·哈代在几十年前写的《德伯家的苔丝》中就谈到了“现代主义的痛苦”。你可以看到现代主义小说、现代主义文化在第一次世界大战之前就已经出现。
You could see it in Henry James or in Joseph Conrad or something. But you're absolutely right. For anybody who's ever done English literature at university or something, 1922 is this absolute landmark year because you have, what is it, in February you have the publication of Ulysses, which is James' novel. Yeah, so it's on the second day of the second month of 1922. So it's 2222, which is Joyce's 40th birthday perfect and then at the
你可以在亨利·詹姆斯或约瑟夫·康拉德的作品中看到它。但你绝对是对的。对于任何在大学里学过英国文学之类的人来说，1922年是一个绝对具有里程碑意义的年份，因为——是什么时候？——在二月份，你迎来了詹姆斯的小说《尤利西斯》的出版。是的，所以它是在1922年第二个月的第二天。所以它是22/2/22，这也是乔伊斯的40岁生日，完美。然后在大约
end of the year or towards the end of the year October the publication of T.S. Eliot's The Wasteland so we've got these two great landmarks and let's talk about Joyce first because the interesting thing about Ulysses is that Ulysses is not really a 20s novel because he conceived it so long before he conceived it well before the first world war what 1906 1907 or something and it's set when is it set tom you know when it's set well it's set on the 16th of june 1904 which is um the day that joyce saw well first had a a kind of date with the woman that he would subsequently go on to marry uh who was a uh a chambermaid from galway called splendidly nora barnacle yes um and so the whole novelism is is an attempt to to to bring to life fictionally the dublin that joyce was living in on that day yeah um and it's it's a stupefying
年底或接近年底的10月，出版了T·S·艾略特的《荒原》。所以我们有了这两大里程碑，让我们先来谈谈乔伊斯，因为关于《尤利西斯》有趣的一点是，《尤利西斯》并不是真正意义上的20年代小说，因为他构思它的时间太早了。他在第一次世界大战之前很久就构思好了，大约是1906年、1907年左右。而且它设定的背景是——汤姆，你知道它的背景设定在什么时候吗？好吧，它设定在1904年6月16日，也就是——呃——乔伊斯第一次与他后来与之结婚的女人约会的日子，那是一位来自戈尔威的、名字叫起来非常棒的女服务员，叫诺拉·巴纳克尔，是的。因此，整部小说是一个试图——在小说中重现乔伊斯在那个生活在其中的都柏林的尝试。是的，而且这是一个令人震惊的
achievement but as you say it's it's actually not a novel that is really about the First World War or the convulsions of the age at all. And in fact, Joyce spent the First World War in neutral Switzerland. He did. And kind of affected, oh, is there a war on? Yeah, he did. I mean, and, you know, this 1922 is the year of establishment of the Irish Free State, collapse into civil war.
成就，但正如你所说，它实际上并不是一部真正关于第一次世界大战或那个时代的动荡的小说。事实上，乔伊斯在保持中立的瑞士度过了第一次世界大战。他确实在那里。而且有点像是在装傻：哦，有战争吗？是的，他确实这样。我的意思是，（你知道的）1922年是爱尔兰自由邦成立、陷入内战的一年。
Joyce affects complete lack of interest. Yeah. And in fact, he keeps the British passport till he dies. Yeah, he never had an Irish passport.
乔伊斯装出完全不感兴趣的样子。是的。事实上，他一直保留着英国护照，直到去世。是的，他从来没有过爱尔兰护照。
It's not like he's, he's, you know, he's very, very hostile to British imperialism in, in Ulysses.
这并不是说他——他（你知道的）在《尤利西斯》中对英国帝国主义非常、非常敌视。
The brutish empire. Yeah. And Ulysses, the funny thing about Ulysses is that the point that it's published, it's, it's describing a world that no longer exists. Because at that point, Ireland and Britain have
那个残暴的帝国。是的。而《尤利西斯》有趣的地方在于，在它出版的时候，它所描述的是一个已经不复存在的世界。因为在那时，爱尔兰和英国已经
been embroiled in the Irish War of Independence. And within weeks, as you say, Ireland is going to be engulfed by civil war. So he's describing a Dublin that in some ways, you could argue, has kind of vanished. Well, absolutely it vanished. I mean, because it's this weird combination of incredible imagination, incredible kind of verbal pyrotechnics. You can never quite be sure where he's going to go with his imagination, with his literary styling, with all kinds of radically novel fictional techniques. But at the same time, he is deliberately trying to evoke a specific day. And so he studies all the newspapers
卷入了爱尔兰独立战争。而且就在几周之内，正如你所说，爱尔兰将被内战吞没。所以他所描述的都柏林在某些方面，你可以说已经消失了。哦，绝对是消失了。我的意思是，因为它是一种奇妙的结合，结合了不可思议的想象力和令人难以置信的言辞烟火。你永远无法确切地知道他的想象力、他的文学风格以及各种各样激进新颖的小说技巧会带他去向何方。但与此同时，他也在刻意唤起特定的一天。所以他研究了所有的报纸，
and he writes to people saying, what were you doing on such and such a day? And what was going on? What was shops were there? And all this kind of stuff. And I think that that's the fascination of it is that it's a novel that in a way, very self-consciously tries to fragment the literary traditions of the novel,
并写信给人们问：你在某某天在做什么？当时发生了什么？有什么商店？诸如此类的事情。我认为这正是它的魅力所在，它是一部在某种程度上非常自觉地试图打破小说文学传统的小说，
but also is very, very aware of itself within that tradition. Well, that's what makes it very modernist though, isn't it? Exactly. So rather like Picasso in his cubist phase, the process of kind of deconstruction depends on there being a great tradition to deconstruct i mean that's exactly so when t.s elliott writes the wasteland which we'll come to in a second and he's sort of assembling it from fragments of of poems and of novels and of kind of shakespearean references and so on it's exactly the same thing it's the sort of image of somebody smashing you know taking culture and smashing it into fragments then trying to reassemble them
但同时又对那个传统本身有着非常、非常深刻的认知。嗯，这正是它非常现代主义的地方，不是吗？完全正确。所以，就像毕加索在他的立体主义时期一样，解构的过程依赖于存在一个伟大的传统供其解构。我的意思是，完全是这样。所以当T·S·艾略特写《荒原》（我们一会儿会谈到）时，他是从诗歌、小说以及莎士比亚引文等碎片中拼凑出它的，这完全是同一回事。这就像是一个人把文化拿过来，把它砸成碎片，然后试图重新组装它们，
to make a kind of new myth because there's a lot of myth in both of those i mean what one way perhaps in which joyce like elliot is is fair you know is responding to a sense of the modern so elliot um in his an essay he writes on the metaphysical poets so that's john dunn and people like that he famously says that we can only say that it appears likely that poets in our civilization, as it exists at present, must be difficult. Our civilization comprehends great variety and complexity, and this variety and complexity playing upon a refined sensibility must produce various and complex results. Now, that's also what Joyce is basically doing. Yeah. But even to try and sum up a single day in a single city in the modern world is so difficult. The conventional forms of fiction
以此来创造一种新的神话，因为这两部作品中都有很多神话。我的意思是，乔伊斯和艾略特相似的一个方面，也许在于（你知道的）他对现代感的反应。所以艾略特——在他写的一篇关于玄学派诗人的文章中，也就是约翰·多恩之流——他有一句名言：我们只能说，在我们现存文明中的诗人，似乎必须是困难的。我们的文明包含着巨大的多样性和复杂性，而这种多样性和复杂性作用于精致的感受力，必然会产生各种复杂的结果。现在，这也是乔伊斯基本上在做的事情。是的。但即使是试图总结现代世界中一个单一城市里的一天，也是如此困难。传统的小说形式
are inadequate to it. And so you need to kind of, that's why it has to be difficult. Now, Dominic, of course, you know, your great theme in your wonderful series of books on modern Britain is that, of course, while, you know, the radical artistic talents are doing their stuff, life goes on as normal. Yeah. And, of course, that is the backdrop, both to Ulysses and The Wasteland. So do you know who else actually had her first work published in 1929? Go on, Tom. Amaze me. Amaze me.
已经不足以应对它了。所以你需要——这就是为什么它必须是困难的。现在，多米尼克，当然（你知道的）你在关于现代英国的精彩系列丛书中的伟大主题是，当然，当激进的艺术人才在做他们的事情时，生活照常继续。是的。当然，这也是《尤利西斯》和《荒原》的背景。所以你知道还有谁的第一部作品实际上是在1929年出版的吗？说吧，汤姆。惊艳我吧。惊艳我吧。
Ina Blyton. So Ina Blyton, her first volume of, it was a volume of poetry, her very first line of verse. So this is a fascinating compliment to Elliot in the Wasteland. In the garden very early, Rosamund is walking. And to her surprise, she hears lots of fairies talking oh isn't that nice which in a way so in in in the wasteland yeah people walk along backs of rivers or across london bridge and you hear strange phantasmal voices from different areas of time
伊妮德·布莱顿。所以伊妮德·布莱顿，她的第一卷——那是一卷诗歌——她的第一行诗句。所以这是对艾略特《荒原》的一个极好的赞美：“清晨的花园里，罗莎蒙德正在散步。令她惊讶的是，她听到许多仙子在说话。”哦，这不是很美好吗？在某种程度上，所以在《荒原》中，人们沿着河岸行走，或穿过伦敦桥，你会听到来自不同时空背景的奇怪的幻影般的声音。
well there's a but uh enid blyton said about modernism, and I'm sure she had Joyce in mind particularly, I'm young and normal, and I prefer something more wholesome. That's fantastic. Well, I mean, you see, this is one of the interesting things. So this is arguably, so the people you mentioned, Picasso, Stravinsky, Joyce, Eliot, what they all have in common is not just that they're trying to assemble new myths, new ways of seeing the world
嗯，有一个——但呃，伊妮德·布莱顿对现代主义的评价是——我确信她心里特别想着乔伊斯：“我很年轻而且很正常，我更喜欢更健康的东西。”这太棒了。好吧，我的意思是，你看，这就是有趣的地方之一。所以这可以说是——你提到的这些人：毕加索、斯特拉文斯基、乔伊斯、艾略特，他们共同的不仅仅是他们试图从过去的碎片中、从在20世纪最初几十年里被粉碎的世界中，组装出新的神话、看待世界的新方式。
out of the fragments of the past, out of a world that's been shattered in the first decades of the 20th century. Yeah, these fragments have I shored against my room. Exactly. But they are all, in a way that is, I think, different from the previous couple of generations. They're very controversial. And they delight in being radical and avant-garde
是的，“这些碎片我已为断壁残垣作了抵押”。完全正确。但他们所有人，以一种我认为与前几代人不同、且十分引人争议的方式。他们喜欢成为激进派和前卫派，
and getting terrible reviews. So, you know, people famously kind of walked out of the right of spring and been horrified by it when Stravinsky pioneered it in 1930. And Ulysses in 1922. I mean, 1922 is punctuated by Ulysses getting a series of absolutely terrible and hilarious reviews. So the Daily Herald set six years ofce's life to write and it will take
并获得可怕的评论。所以，（你知道的）人们 famously 离开《春之祭》的演出现场，并在1930年斯特拉文斯基开创它时感到惊恐。还有1922年的《尤利西斯》。我的意思是，1922年的特点就是《尤利西斯》获得了 一系列绝对糟糕且滑稽的评论。所以《每日先驱报》说：“乔伊斯花了他六年时间来写，而我们要花
nearly six years of hours to read the daily express always very robust our first impression is that of sheer disgust a second of irritability a third of boredom reading mr joyce is like making excursion to bolshevist russia well this is a theme we'll come back to and my favorite one is from the sportinging Times. Can you believe the Sporting Times? The Pinkham, as it was called, reviewed Joyce. And it said, it appears to have been written by a perverted lunatic who has made a speciality
差不多六年时间来读。”《每日快报》一如既往地非常强硬：“我们的第一印象是纯粹的厌恶，第二印象是烦躁，第三印象是无聊。阅读乔伊斯先生就像是去布尔什维克俄国远足。”好吧，这是我们稍后会回到的主题。我最喜欢的一条评论来自《体育报》。你能相信《体育报》吗？被称为粉红报的《体育报》对乔伊斯进行了评论。它说：“它似乎是由一个变态的疯子写的，这个疯子专攻
of the literature of the latrine. So, yeah, I mean, this is... Well, of course. So if you are giving the whole of life, so Ulysses follows, well, three people, one of them, Stephen Dedalus, who is basically Joyce, a portrait of the artist as a young man. Then Leopold Bloom, who is a cook-holded Jewish salesman. And then right at the end, this great kind of single sentence soliloquy monologue from Bloom's wife, Molly. But obviously, if you're following these figures through their whole work course of the day, they have to do all kinds of things. So go to the toilet, but also masturbation,
厕所文学。”所以，是的，我的意思是，这是——当然。如果你展现的是生活的全部，那么《尤利西斯》跟随的——好吧，三个人，其中一个是斯蒂芬·代达罗斯，他基本上就是乔伊斯本人，《青年艺术家画像》中的形象。然后是利奥波德·布鲁姆，一个被戴了绿帽子的犹太推销员。然后直到最后，是布鲁姆的妻子莫莉发表的一段宏大而独白式的单句独白。但很显然，如果你跟随这些人物走过他们一整天的工作历程，他们必须做各种各样的事情。所以要去洗手间，还有手淫、
sexual fantasy. And Joyce was actually, I mean, a tremendous prude. He didn't like vulgarity. I mean, he wrote the occasional erotic letter to Nora Barnacle. But there's so few that when they come up for sale in auctions, you know, they kind of go for 300 grand or whatever. But what reviews get on and on and on about is how obscene it is and how vulgar it is and how common it is. And the person who i know where you're going with this who famously was appalled by it was virginia wool the john lennon of the early 20th century who in my view long run who in the long run would of course but you know mrs
性幻想。而乔伊斯实际上——我的意思是，是一个极其正统的清教徒。他不喜欢粗俗。我的意思是，他偶尔会给诺拉·巴纳克尔写一些色情信件。但数量如此之少，以至于当它们在拍卖会上出售时，（你知道的）它们能拍到30万英镑左右的高价。但评论们没完没了地唠叨的是它是多么的淫秽，它是多么的粗俗，它是多么的下流。而我知道你要把这个归结到谁身上——对此感到震惊的著名人物是弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫，她是20世纪初的约翰·列侬，依我之见，从长远来看，她——从长远来看，当然——但（你知道的）《达洛维夫人》将深受《尤利西斯》的影响，然而她却认为：“……克拉奇酒店里小跑男仆身上的青春痘在挠痒痒……”好吧，我知道有些人——有些我们的听众对弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫情有独钟，我只想说，她是这样形容《尤利西斯》的：“一本不识字、教养低下的书，一个自学成才的工人的书，我们都知道他们是多么令人痛苦，多么的自我中心、固执、粗糙、刺眼，最终令人作呕。”这就是弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫对我们听众的评价，因为我喜欢认为我们的听众绝对是社会的脊梁，
dalloway would be hugely influenced by ulysses but she the scratching of pimples on the body of the boot boy at claridge's well i know some know some of our listeners have a tendresse for Virginia Woolf, and I would merely say, this is how she describes Ulysses, an illiterate underbred book, the book of a self-taught working man, and we all know how distressing they are, how egotistic, insistent, raw, striking, and ultimately nauseating. So that's Virginia Woolf on our listeners, because I like to think our listeners are very much the salt of the earth um and that's why we have a we have a series of penguin classics
这就是为什么我们在家里有一套企鹅经典标志的马克杯，而我拒绝用那个——弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫的马克杯喝水，因为我不会——我不会给伍尔夫太太用她的标志马克杯喝水的满足感。但弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫对《荒原》更感兴趣，是的。所以《荒原》——《荒原》在年底出版。她和T·S·艾略特是好朋友。是的，她是。而《荒原》我认为得到了一个——我的意思是，因为它是一首诗，它没有像小说那样受到大众媒体的严格审视。
kind of branded cups at home and I refuse to drink out of the uh Virginia Woolf mug because I won't I won't give Mrs. Woolf the satisfaction drinking from her branded mug but Virginia Woolf was was keener on the wasteland yeah so the wasteland The Wasteland comes out at the end of the year. She was kind of a mucker of TS Eliot. Yeah, she was. And The Wasteland, I think, gets a... I mean, because it's a poem, it doesn't get the same scrutiny from the popular press as a novel would.
而且《荒原》显然不是有效地——我的意思是，《尤利西斯》并没有出版——在20世纪30年代之前，你在英国是读不到《尤利西斯的》，除非你去法国或其他地方弄一本复印本，而这当然增加了它的恶名，是的，所以它是——我的意思是，这是一本很多人都听说过却没有读过的书，
And The Wasteland obviously isn't effectively... I mean, Ulysses doesn't come out... You can't read Ulysses in Britain until the 1930s unless you go to France or somewhere to get a copy and that of course adds to its notoriety yeah so it's I mean it's a book that lots and lots of people have both heard of and not read yeah and the vast numbers of people who haven't read it is kind of part of its fame whereas The Wasteland I think it's just a poem that most people just haven't read because most people probably don't read much poetry you know this is fantastic story
而绝大多数人没有读过它，这正是它名气的一部分，而《荒原》我认为只是一首大多数人根本没有读过的诗，因为大多数人可能不怎么读诗。你知道这个精彩的故事吗，
about tsa like going to buckingham palace to read it you heard this is this the one with the queen mother giggles yes the giggles he goes to read it to george the sixth the queen mother serious isn't princess elizabeth and print the current queen and princess margaret and he starts reading the queen mother says they the girls start laughing and then she starts laughing and then the king starts laughing and t.s elit is there you know shanty shanty shanty whatever and they're just laughing at him but and i guess the reason for that is that um the wasteland is is again like ulysses it's a difficult poem you know and elit has said poets in our civilization as it exists at present must be be difficult. And what he's essentially doing
关于T·S·艾略特去白金汉宫朗诵这首诗？你听说过这个吗？这是那个王太后咯咯笑的故事吗？是的，咯咯笑。他去为乔治六世朗诵，王太后神情严肃，还有伊丽莎白公主——现任女王——和玛格丽特公主，他开始朗诵，王太后说——姑娘们开始笑，然后她开始笑，然后国王开始笑，而T·S·艾略特就在那里（你知道的）“香提，香提，香提”什么的，而他们只是在笑他。但我想原因在于，呃，《荒原》又是一首像《尤利西斯》一样的困难的诗，（你知道的）艾略特曾说过：“在我们文明中的诗人，正如它目前所存在的那样，必须是困难的。”而他本质上在做的是，
is that he's saying that after the war, maybe before that, civilization has been smashed into so many pieces that you can only have fragments. And so you read it, and it is a kind of bewildering compendium of voices. And a bit like a Picasso painting, there may be a hint of a guitar or a ball in a you know
他说，在战争之后，也许在此之前，文明已经被砸成了如此多的碎片，以至于你只能拥有碎片。所以你阅读它，它是一部令人眼花缭乱的声音汇编。就像毕加索的绘画一样，里面可能暗示了一把吉他或几何图形中的球，你会被某种东西击中——所以，呃，在对的（你知道的）“四月是最残忍的月份”这是著名的开篇，然后突然你会听到这个女孩的声音：“当我们还是孩子，住在总督的府邸时，我的表亲们，他带我出去坐雪橇，我很害怕……”总督——我的意思是，它没有说明总督是谁，但这里有引发战争的那起事件的回响。整首诗基本上就是这样运作的。（你知道的）你会听到非常、非常阳春白雪的声音。你会听到外语的声音。你会听到通俗的声音。
a geometric shape you get kind of hit so um in right you know april's cruelest month is famously the opening and then suddenly you get this the voice of this girl um and when we were children staying at the archduke's my cousins he took me out on a sled and i was frightened um the archduke i mean it's not saying who the archduke's, my cousins, he took me out on a sled and I was frightened. The Archduke. I mean, it's not saying who the Archduke is, but there's the echo of the incident that began the war. And the whole poem kind of operates like that. You know, you get you get very, very highbrow voices. You get voices in foreign languages. You get demotic voices.
它是令人迷失方向的，我认为其冲击力非常惊人。同样，庞德对这一点有着至关重要的影响，因为艾略特把它的初稿发给了他，他对其进行了修改，他做出了我历来最喜欢的反应——一个朋友在阅读另一个朋友的作品时说：“恭喜你，你这个婊子。我被七种嫉妒折磨得死去活来。”我想，如果作家们足够坦诚的话，我们都有过这种稍微好一点的感觉。没错，因为当你的一位朋友
And it's it's disorienting and i think brilliant in its impact and again pound has a crucial influence on this because he elliot sends him the first draft of it and he revises it and he has what is my all-time favorite response of um a friend reading uh another friend's work compliment Complimentary, you bitch. I am wracked by the seven jealousies. And I think if writers are being honest, we've all slightly better. That's right, because when a friend of yours
发给你一些东西让你阅读时，你基本上希望它是——你不想让它很糟糕，但你希望它仅仅比平庸稍微好一点，对吧？而当它极其精彩时，你会想：哦，不，太糟糕了。是的，也许其中有那么一点点成分。仅仅比平庸稍微好一点，对吧？当它极其精彩时，你会想：哦，不，是的，是的。
sends you something to read, you basically want it to be, you don't want it to be terrible, but you want it to be just slightly better than mediocre, don't you? And when it's brilliant, you just think, oh no, disastrous. Yeah, there's perhaps a slight element of that. slightly better than mediocre don't you when it's brilliant you just think oh no yeah yeah
但是（你知道的）退一步讲——特别从《荒原》来看——我的意思是，我们一会儿就要谈到20年代的政治，但在我看来，它身上深深地烙上了第一次世界大战的印记——我的意思是，那是成群的死者走过——是伦敦桥吗？“幻影之城，在冬日黎明的棕色雾气下，一群人涌过伦敦桥，人数如此之多，我未曾料到死亡竟夺去了如此多的人的生命。”这有点——我的意思是，1922年的每个人都生活在一个这样的世界里：
but you know standing back from from particularly from the wasteland um i mean we're going to come on to the politics of the 20s in a second um but to me it feels so indelibly marked by the great war i mean it's that moment when there are the crowds of the dead coming across the, is it London Bridge? Unreal city under the brown fog of a winter dawn, a crowd flowed over London Bridge, so many I had not thought death had undone so many. And that's sort of, I mean, everybody in 1922 is living in a world
（你知道的）每条街上都有家庭在为战争中失去的亲人服丧，许多旧有的确定性都被摧毁了。帝国、国家、假设、政党、机构等等。但当然还有西班牙流感。我的意思是，从我们如今饱受新冠疫情折磨的视角来看，那是一件非常重大的事情。好吧，我的意思是——“冬日黎明的棕色雾气”那个短语，我记得——实际上在封锁最严厉的时候走过伦敦桥——并记得那是去年一月——记得“冬日黎明的棕色雾气”那个短语作为疾病的象征，是的。并且某种——呃——当我们谈到政治时，人们使用的许多语言，他们谈到病毒和细菌以及布尔什维克主义的病菌等等，而这些东西里面有一种病态。有一位历史学家叫理查德·奥弗里，他写过一本关于英国、关于20世纪20和30年代英国文化的精彩的书，名叫《病态的年代》。他在书中一次又一次地谈到，人们有一种文明已经破裂的感觉，随之而来的是不可避免的厄运、衰落和退化在等待着。
where, you know, there are families on every street who are mourning people lost in the war, where so many of the old certainties have been destroyed. Empires, countries, assumptions, political parties, institutions, and so on. But also, of course, Spanish flu. I mean, that's one thing that that really looms large now looking from our sort of covid stricken viewpoint well that i mean that phrase the brown fog of a winter dawn i remember um actually walking across london bridge in the depths of the lockdown uh and remembering that it was last january remembering that that phrase the brown the brown fog of a winter dawn as emblematic of disease yeah and the sort of uh when we come onto the politics so much of the language that people
而这本质上就是《荒原》的主题，它并没有真正提供救赎。好吧，在最后，有一种——水不是落在了干燥的土地上吗？有点，算是吧。但从长远来看，艾略特将通过变得非常保守来找到救赎。所以他受洗加入了英国国教。
use they talk about viruses and germs and the bacillus of Bolshevism and stuff and and that stuff is there's a kind of morbidity there's a historian called Richard Overy who's written a brilliant book about Britain, about British culture in the 1920s and 30s called The Morbid Age. And he talks again and again in this book about how there's this sense of civilization having cracked and then inevitable doom and decadence and degeneracy awaiting.
他成为了一种保皇党和传统主义者。他确实把他在《荒原》中砸碎的伟大的传统遗产重新缝合在了一起。所以也许这一点得到了那个提供资金出版《标准》杂志的女性的认可，这是一本出版了《荒原》的杂志。是的。所以人们总是搞错现代主义的出版物，因为他们认为这全都是关于小杂志和《标准》等等。但实际上，当然，如你所知，汤姆，《标准》杂志的资金是由
And that is essentially the theme of The Wasteland, and it doesn't really offer redemption. Well, at the end, there's the sort of, doesn't the water fall on the dried earth? Kind of, kind of. But in the long run, Eliot will find redemption in becoming very conservative. So he gets baptised into the Church of England.
罗瑟米尔勋爵的夫人罗瑟米尔爵士夫人资助的，罗瑟米尔勋爵是《每日邮报》的老板。当然，《每日邮报》在现代主义的起源中也扮演了非常重要的角色，因为约瑟夫·康拉德曾是《每日邮报》的忠实读者，事实上还在某个时期签署了一份合同，成为《每日邮报》的专栏作家。你知道这件事吗？伟大的作家。
He becomes a kind of royalist and a traditionalist. And he does kind of stitch back together the great kind of inheritance of tradition that he smashed in the wasteland. And so maybe that was recognized by the woman who provided the money to publish the Criterion, which is the magazine in which The Wasteland was published. Yes. So people always get the publications wrong with modernism because they think it's all about little magazines and the Criterion and so on. But actually, of course, as you know, Tom, the money for the Criterion is put up by
《每日邮报》只雇佣最好的人。好吧，你知道吗？约瑟夫·康拉德，他其实无法应付这个。他很不擅长赶截稿日期。他觉得吗？他的正直不允许他这么做。不，他不是。他极其渴望这样做。我认为在某些方面，约瑟夫·康拉德对《每日邮报》来说可能太保守了。他无法按时完成。所以你知道他找谁来帮他代笔文章吗？不，我不知道。诗人爱德华·托马斯。太棒了。
Lady Rothermere, the wife of Lord Rothermere, proprietor of the Daily Mail. And of course, the Daily Mail also played a very important part in the genesis of modernism, because Joseph Conrad had been a great Daily Mail man, and indeed at one point signed a contract to be a columnist for the Daily Mail. Did you know this? Great writers.
爱德华·托马斯以约瑟夫·康拉德的名义为《每日邮报》撰稿。觉得怎么样？但你知道庞德对罗瑟米尔一家的看法吗？不，我不知道。哦，不，汤姆。“罗瑟米尔一家，”庞德严厉地写信给艾略特，“是一个对优秀的文学不感兴趣的家族。”好吧，艾略特并不认同，因为艾略特不仅出版了《荒原》和《标准》，
The Daily Mail employs nothing but the best. Well, you know what? Joseph Conrad, he couldn't get on with this, actually. He wasn't good at writing to deadline. Did he find it? His integrity wouldn't allow him. No, he did not. He desperately wanted to do it. I think in some ways, Joseph Conrad was probably too conservative for the Daily Mail. He couldn't do it on time. So do you know who he got to ghostwrite his articles for him? No, I don't. The poet Edward Thomas. Brilliant.
而且在凯文·杰克逊关于1922年的书中——我知道你读过——《天才星座》。里面有一个长长的注释，我想是的，他在谈论一场审判，其中一对夫妇被判——他们因谋杀妻子的丈夫而被绞死。而那个妻子，这是一个非常——所以基本上这个女人在偷情。她对她的情人说：天哪，我希望我丈夫死。所以她的情人杀了她的丈夫。他从灌木丛里跳出来，对吧？他确实是。
Edward Thomas wrote for the Daily Mail as Joseph Conrad. How about that? But you know, Pound's take on the Rothermears. No, I don't. Oh, no, Tom. A family, Pound wrote damningly to Elliot. The Rothermears are a family which is not interested in good literature. Well, Elliot did not agree because not only did Elliot publish The Wasteland and The Criterion,
所以那个情人理所当然地被判有罪并被绞死，但她也被判了罪，尽管她并不是真的——你知道的——她并不是谋杀的共犯之类，凶手也说她不是，是的——所以基本上非常严厉，非常严厉。对此有巨大的抗议，而《每日邮报》采取了一种非常——你知道的——强硬的立场……史蒂芬·劳伦斯？不，它采取了一种非常强硬的……哦，它做了。好吧。艾略特也这么认为。艾略特认为——
but in Kevin Jackson's book about 1922, I know you've read. Constellation of Genius. He has a full note, I think it is, where he's talking about a trial where a couple have been, they've been hanged for the murder of the woman's husband. And the woman, it's a very, so basically this woman was having an affair. And she said to her lover, God, I wish my husband was dead. So her lover killed her husband. He jumped out of a bush, didn't he? He did.
艾略特写信给报纸说：感谢上帝，你们采取了如此强硬的立场。我很高兴你们没有陷入那种……他叫它什么来着？软弱的伤感。关于绞刑的某种言论。所以艾略特希望更多的人被绞死。所以，不管怎样……
So the lover was understandably found guilty and hangs but so was she even though she hadn't really meant you know she hadn't really been an accessory to it or anything and the murderer said that she wasn't yeah so basically very harshly very harshly there's a tremendous outcry about it and the daily mail took a very, you know, robust... Stephen Lawrence? No, it took a very robust... Oh, it did it. Okay. So did Elliot. Elliot thought...
艾略特非常强硬。好吧，“强硬”可能不是——而且有点像弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫，他有点势利。艾略特非常强硬。好吧，“强硬”可能不是一个词。而且有点像弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫，他有点势利。他确实有点，是的。他还痴迷于长青春痘的男人。是的，他是。就像弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫
And Elliot wrote to the paper and said, thank God you've taken such a strong view. I'm glad you haven't gone in for that... What did he call it? Flaccid sentimentality. Something about hanging. So Elliot wanted more women to be hanged. So anyway...
喋喋不休地谈论那些满脸青春痘的人。是那个“生疮的年轻男子”吗？“生疮的年轻男子，那种自信就像丝绸礼帽戴在布拉德福德百万富翁头上一样。”我们大概应该休息一下，汤姆，因为我们已经陷入了……
Elliot was very robust. Well, robust is probably not... And a bit like Virginia Woolf, he was a bit of a snob. Elliot was very robust. Well, robust is probably not a word. And a bit like Virginia Woolf, he was a bit of a snob. He was a bit, actually, yes. He also was obsessed with spotty men. Yeah, he was. So like Virginia Woolf
我觉得我们陷入其中了吗？我觉得我们正在展翅高飞。你看到了吗？是的。我认为作家给《每日邮报》写信，这真的是陷入泥潭的定义。但我认为休息之后，
going on about the spotty people. Is it the young man carbuncular? The young man carbuncular, one of the low on whom assurance sits as a silk hat on a Bradford millionaire. Right. We should probably take a break, Tom, because we've got quite bogged down in...
我们要做的就是退后一步，拓宽视野，我们来谈谈这一切的背景，也就是所有那些旧确定性的破碎、帝国的崩溃以及国际视野，所以——我们休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的剩余》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。
I think we've got bogged down? I think we were taking wing. Have you seen? Yeah. I think in writers writing to the Daily Mail, I think that's really the definition of getting a bit bogged down. But I think after the break,
如果你想要无广告广播、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的剩余》，我们正在讨论1922年，今年是100年前，多米尼克，呃，你非常热衷于做这个节目，因为你严肃地认为这是现代在某种意义上开始的一年。但当然，1922年存在于一战那场巨大的文明粉碎的背景之中。那么世界在战后是如何疗伤的呢？
what we'll do is we will step back a bit and widen our focus, and we'll talk about the context for all this, which is the splintering of all those old certainties the collapse of empires and the international outlook so uh we shall see you after the break i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
嗯，我认为“疗伤”并不是真正的词，实际上。普遍有一种废墟的感觉，我想。我想也许在后半部分……甚至可以说是一片荒原。是的，我们实际上要围绕这个做两期节目，对吧？我想在后半部分，我们应该特别关注三个国家。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. hello welcome back to the rest is history we are talking 1922 it's 100 years ago this year and dominic um you're very keen on doing this um because you're seriously arguing that this is a year where in a sense kind of the modern begins. But of course, 1922 exists in the context of the monumental civilizational smash-up that was the Great War. So how is the world kind of healing in the wake of the war?
其中一个，最明显的一个，遭到了残害、肢解……被剥夺了财产。是的，就是德国。所以德国失去了它的帝国。它被缩减了。实际上，1922年对德国来说并不是——我的意思是，它不像某些年份那样糟糕。
Well, I don't think healing is really the word, actually. There's a general sense of rubble, I think. And I think maybe in this sort of second half... A wasteland, even. Yeah, it's very much a wasteland. So we're going to do two episodes on this, really, aren't we? And I think in this second half, we should concentrate on three countries in particular.
所以德国经历了一场革命。斯巴达克同盟和自由军团之间曾有过战斗，但大体上魏玛共和国已经把事情重新控制住了，不过有一些
So one of them, the most obvious one that has been sort of maimed, dismembered... Porporized. Yeah, is Germany. So Germany has lost its empire. It's been reduced. Actually, 1922 specifically is not, I mean, it's not as bad as some years for Germany.
风吹草动的迹象，比如希特勒加入了纳粹党，他成为了纳粹党，他在慕尼黑制造麻烦，完全没错，他正在发表
So Germany has gone through a revolution. There has been kind of fighting between the Spartacists and the Freikorps but by and large the Weimar Republic has kind of got things back under control there are sort of
煽动性的啤酒馆演讲来针对准军事组织，所以这是他发现自己拥有——
straws in the wind though so Hitler has joined the Nazi party he's become the Nazi party he's making mischief in Munich exactly he's sort of giving
他拥有，完全没错。最初作为某种准军事组织渗透进纳粹党。所以这是他发现自己拥有演讲天赋的时刻。他确实拥有，完全没错。所以最初作为某种军队的线人渗透进纳粹党。是的，完全没错。他已经成为了纳粹党伟大的演说家，并成为了
rabble rousing beer hall speeches to kind of paramilitary so this is the point where he's discovered his gift for
它的领袖。但他还没有获得他后来将拥有的那种全国性的追随者，因为他还没有搞他的那种啤酒馆暴动。所以他仍然是一个煽动性的蛊惑者，而不是某种全国性的政治玩家。但你确实有一种感觉，我认为，在德国。所以有一个叫瓦尔特·拉特瑙的人，
he has exactly so having infiltrated the Nazi party initially as a kind of paramilitary. So this is the point where he's discovered his gift for oratory. He has, exactly. So having infiltrated the Nazi party initially as a kind of army sort of informer. Yeah, exactly. He has become the great orator of the Nazi party and has become
他是谈判达成协议的外交部长。他被暗杀了他被暗杀了，完全是被右翼准军事组织暗杀的。所以有一种真实的感觉，即魏玛共和国核心的不稳定性。你在德国也能看到那种文化表现——
its leader. But he hasn't quite got the sort of national following that he'll get later because he hasn't done his kind of beer hall putsch yet. So he's still a sort of demagogic rabble-razzer rather than a sort of national player. But you do have a sense, I think, in Germany. So there's a guy called Wouter Rathenau,
病态和解体。所以你有一些电影，比如《诺斯费拉图》。是的。《德古拉》的重新演绎，不是吗？完全正确，是对《德古拉》吸血鬼故事的重新演绎。而那种迷恋，
who is the foreign minister who negotiates a deal. He gets assassinated. He gets assassinated exactly by right-wing paramilitaries. So there's a real sense of the instability at the core of the Weimar Republic. You also have in Germany the sort of the cultural expression of the kind of
在20世纪20年代德国表现主义电影文化中存在一种吸血鬼式的迷恋。乔治·格罗斯的漫画太可怕了。极其可怕、具有讽刺意味和刻薄。
the morbidity and the dissolution. So you have things like the film Nosferatu. Yeah. Reworking of Dracula, isn't it? Exactly, of Dracula, a vampire story. And that sort of obsession,
morbidity与瓦解。所以你会看到像电影《诺斯费拉图》这样的作品。是的。对《德古拉》的改编，对吧？正是如此，改编自《德古拉》，一个吸血鬼的故事。而那种痴迷，
there's a kind of vampiric obsession in German expressionist kind of cinematic culture in the 20s. George Grace's cartoons are horrible. Incredibly horrible, scatological scathing.
在20年代的德国表现主义电影文化中，有一种吸血鬼式的痴迷。乔治·格罗斯的漫画非常恐怖。极其恐怖、充满排泄物联想且刻薄尖锐。
All of that stuff. Yeah. Or Fritz Lang does his first Dr. Mabusev films in 1922. Again, sort of brooding, dark, sort of vampiric stuff. So famously, in the long run, the Nazis will come to power by saying that Germany hadn't actually lost the First World War. They've stabbed in the back. In 1922, do Germans feel that they are a defeated people or do they feel that they've been betrayed
诸如此类的事情。是的。或者说弗里茨·朗在1922年拍摄了他的第一部《马布斯博士》系列电影。同样，这是一种令人焦虑、黑暗、带有吸血鬼色彩的题材。众所周知，从长远来看，纳粹党正是通过宣称德国实际上并没有输掉第一次世界大战而夺取政权的。他们是被背叛的。在1922年，德国人觉得自己是一个战败的民族，还是觉得自己被背叛了
and that they could have carried on? I think it depends on the German, actually. I think some, you know, let's say the people that Ratanau kind of represents, so that would be the kind of, you know, you have a part of Germany that is invested in the Weimar Republic, and they would be kind of liberal-minded, middle-class, sort of democratically-minded people. But you have an enormous number of people in the kind of conservative, on the conservative wing of the spectrum, who, you know, they don't really ever
并且他们本可以继续打下去？我觉得这因人而异吧。我认为有些人，比如说，拉特瑙所代表的那类人，也就是德国有一部分人是全力支持魏玛共和国的，他们会是那种思想开明、中产阶级、具有民主意识的人。但你在保守派阵营中能看到数量庞大的人，他们实际上从不
accept the legitimacy of the Weimar Republic. They do think that Germany was betrayed in some way. I mean, this is the argument that Erich Ludendorff, former sort of co-dictator of Germany at the end of the First World War, is pushing by this point in the early 20s. He's saying, well, we could have fought on, but the politicians wouldn't let us and we were betrayed by fifth columnists and all this sort of thing. And obviously the chief scapegoats are the jews um and you and you definitely see this already and there's a sort of paramilitary quality of german politics already yeah um and part of that so the communists fighting um the the right the hard right yeah um in berlin and munich and and
承认魏玛共和国的合法性。他们确实认为德国在某种程度上受到了背叛。我的意思是，这也是埃里希·鲁登道夫在20年代初所鼓吹的论调，他曾是一战末期德国的实际共同独裁者。他当时说，其实我们本可以继续抵抗，但政客们不让我们这么做，我们被内奸之流给背叛了诸如此类。很显然，主要的替罪羊就是犹太人，嗯，而且你绝对已经能看到这种现象了，德国政治已经带有一种准军事化的性质了，是的，嗯，其中一部分就是共产主义者在柏林和慕尼黑等地
so on presumably what the effect of that is that it is kind of delegitimising every kind of authority, every kind of break on the resort to violence. Yeah. I think violence, a kind of paramilitary violence, is built into, is
与右翼、极右翼进行武装斗争，嗯，其产生的影响想必就是，它在某种程度上使各种权威以及对诉诸暴力的所有约束都失去了合法性。是的。我认为暴力，一种准军事化的暴力，自始至终就已经嵌入了
implicit in the post-war Germany from the very beginning. Because its early months are scarred by so much fighting, kind of attempt to set up a Soviet in Munich and so on, kind of Bavarian socialist republic, endless sort of putches
战后德国的骨子里，并成为其隐含的特征。因为它的头几个月就充斥着大量的战斗，比如在慕尼黑试图建立苏维埃政权等等，也就是所谓的巴伐利亚社会主义共和国，还有没完没了的暴动
and coups and so on and this sort of sense of that the Weimar, thatimar Republic never has, it never really commands widespread acceptance across German society. And I think that means that although later on in the 20s there has this brief period where it seems like it's becoming a bit more stable,
和政变之类的事情，这种感觉让魏玛，让魏玛共和国从来没有、也从未真正在整个德国社会中获得广泛的认可。我认为这意味着，尽管后来在20年代有过一段短暂的时期，看起来它似乎变得稍微稳定了一些，
that's after the great inflation of 1922-1933 has abated. So the inflation. Yeah. So the inflation. Yeah. And the inflation is absolutely crazy. That's the key. I mean, that's the real killer. Yeah. So the inflation, I think at the beginning of 22, a mark is worth, you can get something like 350 marks to the dollar. And by the end of 1922, it something like um what is i mean it sounds unbelievable 7400 marks to the dollar so that's a i'm in a colossal change a colossal sort of debauching of your currency and then by late 1923 it's billions of marks to the dollar so i mean
那是在1922至1923年的超级通货膨胀平息之后。也就是通货膨胀。对。也就是通货膨胀。对。而且那场通货膨胀简直疯狂至极。这才是关键所在。我的意思是，那才是真正的致命杀手。对。所以这场通货膨胀，我认为在22年年初的时候，一个马克还值，你可以用差不多350马克兑换一美元。而到了1922年底，大概变成了——嗯，这听起来简直不可思议——7400马克兑换一美元，所以这真的是一个极其巨大的变化，货币贬值到了丧心病狂的地步，然后到了1923年底，美元对马克变成了几十亿比一，所以我的意思是
that's your classic image of the wheelbarrows full of banknotes. And obviously that destroys people's savings. It erodes middle-class people's faith in the system. And it pauperizes the middle classes. Yeah, completely. Absolutely. And a pauperized middle class is always the wellspring of revolutionary activity. And don't forget that all this is happening, Tom, against the backdrop of what we're going to talk about in a few minutes, which is Bolshevism, which is the arrival of what we're going to talk about in a few minutes which is bolshevism which is the arrival of the russian revolution i think okay but dominic just on the topic so we're looking at 1922 as you know the year that modernity begins one of one of the enduring
这就是手推车装满钞票的经典画面。很显然，这摧毁了人们的储蓄。它侵蚀了中产阶级对这个体制的信念，并且让中产阶级陷入了赤贫。是的，完全如此。绝对是这样。而一个陷入赤贫的中产阶级永远是革命活动的源泉。别忘了，所有这一切发生的时候，汤姆，正值我们几分钟后要谈论的背景之下，也就是布尔什维克主义，也就是我们几分钟后要谈论的布尔什维克主义的到来，也就是俄国革命的到来，好吧，不过多米尼克，就这个话题而言，我们把1922年看作是你所说的现代性开端的一年，其中一个持久
effects of the great inflation in germany is a german horror at inflation. Yeah. Which has been a massive, massive factor in the evolution of the European Union. It has, yes, that's true. So in that sense, the economics of Germany in 1922 continue to reverberate right the way up into the present day. Yeah, I think they do,
影响就是德国人对通货膨胀的巨大恐惧。是的。这成为了欧洲一体化演变过程中一个极其重大的因素。确实如此，是的，千真万确。所以从这个意义上说，1922年德国的经济状况至今仍在产生回响。是的，我认为确实如此，
because of course, the German response to the Eurozone crisis was partly informed by the fact that generations of German politicians have always sort of said, never again, you know, inflation is the great enemy, which is ironic because actually the thing that really brought the Nazis to power was not the inflation. It was the unemployment caused by the onset of the Great Depression
因为当然，德国对欧元区危机的反应，部分原因在于历代德国政客总是会说：绝不重蹈覆辙，通货膨胀是最大的敌人。这其实挺讽刺的，因为真正把纳粹推上台的其实并不是通货膨胀，而是1931年后大萧条爆发所导致的失业。但是，说来奇怪，通货膨胀反倒成了魏玛德国及其治理失败的标志性画面……嗯，我想是因为战前的德国太富裕、繁荣和成功了，以至于那个……
after 1931. But, you know, it's the inflation, oddly, that has become the defining image of Weimar Germany, of its failure to... Well, I suppose Germany was so rich and prosperous and successful before the war that the, you know, impoverished bourgeois carrying mark notes on wheelbarrows. I mean, it's...
嗯，推着手推车带着马克纸币的贫困资产阶级。我的意思是，这……
Well, I think actually what you get is... I don't know if you've read that book by... So Colm Tabin had a book last year about Thomas Mann and a novel about the life of Thomas Mann. So Thomas Mann wrote
嗯，其实我觉得你看到的是……我不知道你有没有读过那本书……科姆·托宾（Colm Tóibín）去年出过一本关于托马斯·曼的书，是一部关于托马斯·曼生平的小说。托马斯·曼写过
the great book about kind of bourgeois German Victorianism, Buddenbrooks, about this family in Lübeck. And when you read the Colm Tabin book about Mann's life,
那本关于资产阶级德国维多利亚主义的伟大著作《布登勃罗克斯一家》，讲述了吕贝克这样一个家族的故事。当你读到科姆·托宾关于曼生平的书时，
just that journey that nobody really in the English speaking world can possibly contemplate, that you go from pre-war, you know, Germany, the most dynamic, the most sort of self-satisfied, prosperous country in Europe. And in many ways, most progressive. Yeah. And very progressive to this basket case in the 1920s
你会发现英语世界里没有人能够真正想象的那段旅程：你从战前的德国——欧洲最具活力、最自满、最繁荣的国家，在很多方面也是最进步的国家——
and then the horrors of the 30s and 40s and so on. I mean, it's just the most extraordinary trajectory. And so if we're talking about the horrors of the 1930s and 40s, and indeed the horrors of the 20th century generally, the fact that... So 1922 is a key year
一路走向20年代的烂摊子，然后是30和40年代的种种恐怖等等。我的意思是，这段轨迹简直非同寻常。所以如果我们谈论30和40年代的恐怖，乃至整个20世纪的恐怖，事实上……所以1922年是一个关键年份，在于……
in... So it's the establishment of the soviet union yeah it's effectively the establishment of stalin's primacy because although lenin is still alive he's had the stroke and stalin has made himself general secretary of the communist party and he uses this as a way to essentially muscle out the opposition and bring Lenin under his thumb. So communism, obviously, is a massive theme for the decades that are to come. But also in 1922, and we did an episode on the Rubicon a little bit earlier this week, but you have Mussolini's March on Rome,
苏联的建立，是的，这实际上确立了斯大林的最高地位。尽管列宁还活着，但他中风了，斯大林让自己担任了共产党总书记，并以此为手段基本上排挤了反对派，将列宁置于自己的掌控之下。所以共产主义显然是未来几十年中的一个巨大主题。但同样是在1922年，我们在本周早些时候做过一期关于卢比孔河的节目，墨索里尼发起了向罗马进军，
and so the rise of fascism. Absolutely. And I think those two things are completely intertwined. So what happens in italy well maybe we'll come on to russia in just a second um so italy italy had entered the first world war very foolishly in my view to try and get more territory it had basically changed sides um done a dirty deal to come in on the allied side because they want to snatch bits of the austro-hungarian empire um. The Italian army had performed incredibly poorly.
由此迎来了法西斯主义的崛起。绝对是这样。而且我认为这两者是完全交织在一起的。那么意大利发生了什么？好吧，也许我们一会儿再转到俄罗斯，嗯——意大利在第一次世界大战中非常愚蠢地参战了，在我看来，是为了试图获得更多领土。它基本上临阵倒戈，
Soldiers very heroically, but the generals utterly inept. They'd lost 700,000 men. They'd run up colossal debts. They'd gained virtually nothing. And at the end of the war, as they see it, they're fobbed off by the other allies. They're not given the great empire they want in the Adriatic. They're given a bit of territory,
做了一笔肮脏的交易加入了协约国阵营，因为他们想抢夺奥匈帝国的领土碎片。意大利军队的表现糟糕透顶。
but nothing like what they think they're going to get. And there's this tremendous sense in Italy that they have been utterly shortchanged, that they've had this horrendous experience. I mean, the fighting, the Italian front. They're kind of blowing off the tops of mountains,
士兵非常英勇，但将领们极度无能。他们损失了70万士兵，背负了巨额债务，却几乎一无所获。在战争结束时，在他们看来，他们被其他协约国无情地打发了。他们没有得到他们想要的在亚得里亚海的大帝国，只得到了零星的一点领土，
aren't they? It's awful. It's absolutely awful. They fight. There's the battle of the Asonzo. There were 12 battles of the Asonzo. They're just constantly charging at the Austrians and just being machine gunned. So, some of all, I went to Lake Como, which I'd never been to, and climbed up a mountain.
根本无法和他们预期得到的相比。意大利有一种极其强烈的感觉，那就是他们遭到了彻底的欺骗，经历了一场可怕的灾难。我的意思是，那些战斗，意大利前线。他们简直是在把山顶炸飞，
And there was this tunnel that kind of went through. I mean, it went through a mountain that had been hacked out with handpicks. And you just saw the absolute waste of effort that went into all that. The Italian front is so horrible that there are all these stories of Italians charging up their caste, which is this sort of exposed limestone mountainous region
不是吗？太可怕了。简直太可怕了。他们浴血奋战。那是伊松佐河战役，一共有十二次伊松佐河战役。他们就是不断地向奥地利人冲锋，然后被机枪扫射。总之，我去了一次科莫湖，我以前从未去过，还爬上了一座山。
in the sort of Italian-Slovenian border. There are all these stories of Italians charging up these hillsides, and the Austrians at the top of the hill shouting at them to go back basically saying if you if you turn back and run away we won't shoot at you because you know we're going to kill you and they the italians just keep coming and the austrians just mow them down and the austrian army is completely inept itself so the fact that it's able to hold off the italians yeah tells you how badly the italian generals are performing anyway um this is a bit of a segue a bit of sidetrack rather uh the attack Italy is a terrible in a terrible state at the end
那里有一个穿山而过的隧道。我的意思是，那是用手镐硬生生地在一座山里凿出来的隧道。你一眼就能看出为这一切付出的努力是多么巨大的浪费。意大利前线是如此可怕，以至于流传着各种各样的故事：意大利人冲上喀斯特高原，那是位于意大利和斯洛文尼亚边境一带裸露的石灰岩山区。
of the first world war it's absolutely in the early 20s it is riven by labor unrest there are whole waves of factory occupations there's tremendous unemployment there's great hostility sort of class hostility and so on. And what you have by 1922 is that this guy, who has been a socialist journalist, Mussolini, completely shamelessly basically changes his colours and offers his support and basically all the radical energy that he had previously put into the left-wing sort of cause he basically gets into bed with the landowners the factory owners and the right and says you know my squad
到处都有这样的故事：意大利人冲上这些山坡，山顶的奥地利人朝着他们大喊，叫他们滚回去，基本上是在说：如果你转头逃跑，我们就不朝你开枪了，因为你知道的，我们要把你消灭掉。而意大利人却源源不断地冲上来，奥地利人则把他们无情地割倒。奥地利军队本身也极其无能，所以它竟然能够抵挡住意大利人，这说明意大利将领的表现有多么糟糕。无论如何，这有点题外话了，有点偏离正题了——战争结束时，
risti my my squads my kind of paramilitary units are at your disposal to fight off bolshevism um and there's a series of punch-ups and there's a real sense of kind of seething violence. And then there's a general strike in the late summer that fails. And against that backdrop, Mussolini launches his famous march on Rome. Which isn't really a march, is it? No, it's an absolute con. It's a complete con.
意大利处于极其糟糕的状况，绝对如此。20年代初的意大利，由于劳资冲突而四分五裂，到处都是工厂被占领的浪潮，失业率高得惊人，阶级敌意等等极其严重。到了1922年，这个人——曾担任社会主义记者的墨索里尼——极其无耻地变节了，转而提供他的支持。他把他以前投入到左翼事业中的所有激进能量，基本上与地主、工厂主和右翼同流合污，并说：你知道吗，我的黑衫军，
He gets up in Naples and sort of gives this tremendous speech saying, we should all march on Rome and seize... Our program is simple. We want to rule Italy. Yeah. But then he doesn't go himself. He's such a coward. He doesn't go.
我的战斗队，我的准军事组织，任凭你们差遣去打击布尔什维克主义。这一时期爆发了一系列殴斗，空气中弥漫着一种暗流汹涌的暴力气息。随后在夏末爆发了一场总在此背景下，墨索里尼发起了他著名的向罗马进军。这其实算不上什么进军，对吧？不，这完全是一场骗局。这是一场彻头彻尾的骗局。
He goes off to Milan instead. Well, they all, he says, you, you, you, you, and you, you can lead the march. I'll just weigh in. And then the king, the king makes him, appoints him prime minister. So the king, it's a really interesting um parallel with what happens in germany in 19 you know the end of 32 early 33 um the italian prime minister is a guy
他在那不勒斯发表了一场极其激昂的演讲，声称我们应该全体向罗马进军并夺取……我们的纲领很简单，我们要统治意大利。然而他自己却没有去。他是个十足的懦夫，他没有去。
called luigi factor and he basically says you know these fascists are a rabble there's 20 000 of them they're pouring with rain they're very bedraggled we don't have anything to fear from them i've got more troops i'll declare a state of emergency, crush them, you know, and it'll be fine. And the king panics and refuses to sign the order of Victor Emmanuel III. And he says, he thinks, no, maybe the
相反，他去了米兰。好吧，他们所有人——他说：你、你、你、你，还有你，你们可以领导进军。我稍后会介入。然后国王，国王让他担任了首相。所以国王——这与1932年底到1933年初发生在德国的事情有着非常有趣的相似之处……当时的意大利首相是一个叫
thing to do is, because he's obviously quite conservative himself, he thinks maybe the thing to do is bring Mussolini on side, you know, and let's not have any trouble. And he appoints Mussolini as prime minister. And Mussolini turns up for the ceremony in his black shirt and the top hat. Yeah. Well, Dan Jackson has been on our podcast
路易吉·法克塔（Luigi Facta）的人，他基本上说：你知道的，这些法西斯分子只是一帮乌合之众，他们只有两万人，正顶着倾盆大雨，狼狈不堪，我们没什么好怕他们的。我有更多军队，我会宣布进入紧急状态，把他们粉碎，那就万事大吉了。然而国王却惊慌失措，拒绝签署维托里奥·埃马纽埃尔三世的命令。他觉得，不，也许应该做的是——
to talk about the birth of the railways and the top hat, but he wasn't wearing a black shirt. No, he wasn't. Well, he also wasn't about to become prime minister of Italy, to be fair to Dan. No, he wasn't. So, yeah, so obviously the rise of fascism in Italy, I mean, if you're looking at 1922, that's an absolutely massive moment
因为他自己显然相当保守——他觉得也许应该做的是把墨索里尼拉拢过来，你知道的，别惹麻烦了。于是他任命墨索里尼为首相。墨索里尼穿着黑衬衫戴着高顶礼帽出席了就职仪式。好吧，丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson）曾做客我们的播客节目，谈论过铁路的诞生和高顶礼帽，但他当时没穿黑衬衫。不，他没穿。嗯，而且公平地说，丹当时也没有即将成为意大利首相。不，他没有。所以，是的，很显然，法西斯主义在意大利的崛起——如果你审视1922年，那绝对是一个极其重大的时刻，
because then people start in Germany saying, where is our Mussolini? Well, but Dominic, you said, so Mussolini goes from being a socialist to being a fascist. Yeah. And that this was a total reversal. In a way, I mean, he's not becoming a kind of supporter of liberal economics or capitalism. No, no, no.
因为随后德国人开始纷纷发问：我们的墨索里尼在哪里？不过，多米尼克，你刚才说，墨索里尼从一个社会主义者变成了法西斯分子。是的。而这是一个彻底的转变。从某种意义上说，他并没有成为某种自由市场经济或资本主义的支持者。不，不，不。
Adam Smith or something. I mean, essentially, the energies of the fascists and the communists, they're so electrifying because they're so similar. Isn't that right? Yeah, you're right. I mean, we could get into a huge conversation here, couldn't we, about the sort of the protein and the sort of the ambiguity. Because they're national socialists. Yeah, the ambiguity of fascism in the early 20s, that it appears both radical and conservative.
亚当·斯密之类的人。我的意思是，本质上，法西斯分子和共产主义者的能量之所以如此具有煽动力，是因为它们太相似了。难道不是吗？是的，你说得对。我的意思是，我们在这里可以展开一场巨大的讨论，对吧，关于那种多变性和某种模糊性。因为他们是国家社会主义者。是的，法西斯主义在20年代初的模糊性在于，它既显得激进又显得保守。
Of course, it appears both modern and anti-modern. So fascist parties classically use radio, cars, planes. They glory in their modernity at the same time as they're harking back to a and idealized yeah to idealize past and and the the guy who blazes the trail for that for Mussolini's Denunzio terrible man absolutely the man who got Italy into the first world war in the first place yeah and and he establishes a kind of proto-fascist state in Trieste which is where Joyce had been where he yeah and of course Denunizio is another poet. Another poet?
当然，它既显得现代又显得反现代。所以法西斯政党通常会使用无线、汽车、飞机。他们在陶醉于现代性的同时，又在怀念一个——一个被理想化的过去。而为墨索里尼开辟这条道路的人是邓农齐奥（d'Annunzio），一个绝对可怕的人，正是他最初把意大利拖入了第一次世界大战。是的，他在的里雅斯特建立了一个准法西斯国家，乔伊斯曾在那儿生活过，而且邓农齐奥也是个诗人。又是一个诗人？
Yeah, like Enid Blyton. Yeah. Okay. Well, anyway, so that's enough about fascists. What about communists? Yeah, I think, you see, I think, I don't know what you think, Tom. I think the two keys to this whole period of the
对，就像伊妮德·布莱顿（Enid Blyton）一样。好吧，无论如何，法西斯的话题就到这里。那么共产主义呢？是的，你看，我认为——我不知道你怎么想，汤姆。我认为贯穿整个时期的两个关键是
Great War and communism, because it's fear of communism that drives a lot of the the sort of right-wing stuff not the right-wing stuff doesn't have roots of its own but i think that paralyzing fear of bolshevism i mean paralyzing is the wrong word actually it's an energy it's an energizing fear of of communism so russia it's had its revolutions um it's been through this period uh sort of from 1918 to 1920 of civil war of this incredibly weird civil war lots of different people and the czechs are involved and the allies are sending troops most of the sort of the civil war is done and dusted by 1920 but there's still
大战和共产主义，因为正是对共产主义的恐惧推动了许多右翼势力——并不是说右翼势力没有其自身的根源——但我认为那种对布尔什维克的瘫痪般的恐惧……麻痹这个词其实不太准确，这是一种能激发能量的对共产主义的恐惧。所以俄罗斯已经历了革命，
they're still mopping up in central asia in 1922 And in fact, extraordinarily, the last Allied forces, so the last Japanese forces, don't leave Siberia until 1922. They're in Vladivostok and they leave in the summer and then the Red Army marches into Vladivostok on the 25th of October. But what's also going on, which
它经历了一段从1918年到1920年的内战时期，这是一场极其诡异的内战，许多不同势力卷入其中，捷克人也介入了，协约国也派遣了军队。绝大部分内战在1920年就已经尘埃落定，但在1922年中亚地区仍在进行清剿。
I hadn't really appreciated until reading up on this, was that there's a lot of attention given to the sort of famine caused by Stalin's collectivisation measures later on. But there's a tremendously horrendous famine in Russia itself in 1922. So about 5 million people probably die of starvation. You don't even... On the Volga.
事实上，令人匪夷所思的是，最后一批协约国军队，即最后一批日本军队，直到1922年才离开西伯利亚。他们当时驻扎在符拉迪沃斯托克（海参崴），直到夏天才撤离，随后红军于10月25日开进符拉迪沃斯托克。不仅如此，我还注意到——
And that barely even registers in places like kazan and samoa yeah exactly that now so much has happened that i mean five million people that that's kind of lost um while the spanish flu is also yeah of course spanish flu is kind of becoming well there are i suppose okay but you've But you've had the First World War, millions die. Spanish flu, millions die. This famine, which I'd never even heard of. I've heard the one in Ukraine, but I haven't heard this one. Something like 10 million people have died in the Russian Civil War.
在阅读相关资料之前我并没有真正意识到这一点——人们把大量的注意力放在了后来斯大林农业集体化措施所导致的饥荒上。但在1922年的俄罗斯本土，也发生了一场极其骇人听闻的饥荒。大约有500万人可能死于饥饿。你甚至……发生在伏尔加河流域。
I mean, colossal. I mean, just unbelievable figures. I mean, you know, and it's like Hitler says, when you start talking about millions, the brain fades. You tune out. I think that's absolutely what happens. The loss of one life is a tragedy. And a million is a statistic, exactly.
而在喀山和萨马拉等地甚至都没怎么引起注意……是的，确实如此。现在发生了太多的事情，以至于500万人——这基本上被淹没不计了。与此同时西班牙流感也……是的，当然，西班牙流感正在演变成……好吧，我是说，你有过第一次世界大战，数百万人死亡；西班牙流感，数百万人死亡；这场我甚至都没听说过的饥荒——我听说过乌克兰的那场，但没听说过这一场。大约有1000万人在俄国内战中丧生。
But the Soviet Union, well, it's not yet the Soviet Union. Russia is in a very uncertain place because they've had what they call war communism, where they basically seized estates and they tried to suppress all capitalism. Then in 1921, Lenin had slightly changed course and he had said, well, we'll allow some rule, some small enterprise to happen and peasants can sell their surpluses. And this is what it's called is new economic policy, NEP. But then, as you say, Lenin has this stroke in May 1922. It's a great what-if, actually, Tom. I mean, it's the great what-ifs that
我的意思是，极其庞大。我的意思是，这简直是让人难以置信的数字。你知道的，正如希特勒所说，当你开始谈论数以百万计的数字时，大脑就会麻木。你会选择屏蔽。我认为这绝对是真实写照。一条生命的消逝是一场悲剧，而一百万人的死亡只是一个统计数字，正是如此。
Trotskyists and Stalinists have argued about for decades. What would have happened if Lenin... What did Lenin really want for Russia? Lenin has this stroke, and as you said, Stalin, he really begins his rise. He controls Lenin, he controls access to Lenin, he really begins his rise. He controls Lenin.
但苏联——好吧，当时还不是苏联。俄罗斯处于一个非常不确定的状态，因为他们实行了所谓的战时共产主义，他们基本上没收了庄园并试图压制所有资本主义。接着在1921年，列宁稍微改变了方针，他说，好吧，我们将允许一些规则、一些小型企业存在，农民可以出售他们的剩余产品。这就是所谓的“新经济政策”，简称NEP。但是随后，正如你所说，列宁在1922年5月突发中风。这其实是一个巨大的“如果”，汤姆。我的意思是，这是托洛茨基主义者和斯大林主义者争论了几十年的那些重大的“如果”之一。如果列宁……列宁对俄罗斯真正的期望是什么？列宁中风了，正如你所说，斯大林真正开始崛起。他掌控了列宁，他掌控了接触列宁的渠道，他真正开始崛起。他掌控了列宁。
He controls access to Lenin. He's general secretary of the party. So he's sharing power with two other guys, particularly Kamenev and Zinoviev. But there is this sort of sense that Stalin, because he has the party machine, he is the coming man. And it's Stalin who is probably the key player in the creation of the USSR. Which is announced in December, is it? December, exactly. They have the big meetings to decide it,
他掌控了接触列宁的渠道。他是党的总书记。所以他与另外两个人（特别是加米涅夫和季诺维也夫）分享权力。但有一种感觉是，斯大林因为掌控了党内机器，他才是那个冉冉升起的人物。而且正是斯大林在苏联的建立中发挥了可能最关键的作用。苏联是在12月宣布成立的，对吗？12月，没错。他们召开了决定性的大会，
so 28th and 30th of December. It's not quite what Lenin wanted. So Lenin had wanted a Union of Soviet Republics of Europe and Asia and Stalin changed the title to the Union of Soviet Socialist Republics. I think partly because Lenin wanted, Lenin seems to have wanted a slightly more kind of federal system.
也就是12月28日和30日。这并不完全是列宁想要的。列宁原本希望建立一个由欧洲和亚洲的苏维埃共和国组成的联盟，而斯大林则将名称改为了“苏维埃社会主义共和国联盟”。我想部分原因是因为列宁希望——列宁似乎想要一个稍微更具联邦制的系统。
He hated the idea of great Russian chauvinism. Liberal. And Stalin, sort of paradoxically, despite the fact he was Georgian, was not so keen on that. He didn't want to encourage nationalism. So they take out the Europe and Asia stuff, and it's just the union of soviet socialist republics and it ends up you know it basically covers the old czarist empire but isn't it also that lenin was um you know in the best marxist sense wanted uh universal revolution um and it's stalin in the long
他痛恨大俄罗斯沙文主义的想法。开明。而斯大林，某种程度上自相矛盾的是，尽管他是个格鲁吉亚人，却并不是很热衷于此。他不想助长民族主义。所以他们去掉了“欧洲和亚洲”的字眼，只剩下苏维埃社会主义共和国联盟，最后它基本上涵盖了旧沙皇帝国的范围……但难道不是因为列宁——你知道的，本着最好的马克思主义精神——想要实现普遍革命吗？而从长远来看，是斯大林选择了在一国建成社会主义。在一个国家。
run who will go for socialism in one country in one country. In one country. Yeah, exactly right. So you're starting to see the process by which the Soviet Union, as it becomes in December, will essentially become a communist equivalent of the Tsarist Empire. Yeah, I think that's right, actually, Tom. Because although for the time being, Stalin is allied to Zinoviev, who wants to kind of export. He's the head of the Comintern. And Trotsky as well, of course.
在一个国家。是的，完全正确。所以你开始看到这样一个进程：正如12月成立的那样，苏联本质上将成为沙皇帝国的共产主义替代品。是的，我认为确实如此，汤姆。因为尽管目前斯大林与想要输出革命的季诺维也夫结盟，他是共产国际的领导人，当然还有托洛茨基。
In charge, of course, of Trotsky. But you're right that he's going to start moving that way. But, of course, nobody else knows this. And I think we've probably gone on long enough on this episode, but this is the point at which we should end this. Nobody else knows that that's where Bolshevism is going to go. So they all think it's going to be exported. And you've got, we mentioned the Comintern. That's why you have partly one reason
当然，托洛茨基也负责此事。但你说得对，他将开始朝着那个方向行动。不过，当然，其他人并不知道这一点。我想我们这期节目大概聊得够久了，但这就是我们应该结束的地方。其他人并不知道布尔什维克主义未来的走向。所以他们都以为它会被输出。而且正如我们提到的共产国际。这就是为什么你会有部分原因
why you have the paramilitary politics in Germany. It's why you have fascism in Italy and so on, because it's against this, I said paralyzing again, and it's completely wrong, this i said i said paralyzing again it's completely wrong this sort of enervating energizing fear um and you see that in i i what i love about the early 20s that i think is so often missed by kind of the the sort of roaring 20s cocktail glasses and f scott fitzgerald view of it is the is the mad kind of paranoia and you see that in so much popular culture so I used to read these books when I was at my at school which were utterly utterly
导致了德国的准军事政治。这也是为什么意大利会出现法西斯主义等等，因为正是针对这种——我刚才又说“瘫痪”，这完全是错的——这种消耗性的、激发能量的恐惧。你从……我喜欢20年代初期的那些东西，常常被“咆哮的二十年代”的鸡尾酒杯和菲茨杰拉德式的视角所忽略，那就是疯狂的偏执，你可以在许多通俗文化中看到这一点。我上学时经常读这些书，它们简直——
inappropriate um I think by today's standards which were the Bulldog Drummond books we talked about Bulldog Drummond yes in James Bond he's an ancestor and in 1922 Sapper who is the um his real name is H.C. McNeill. And yet to pick up a theme of this podcast, Tom, he is encouraged into writing for the Daily Mail. He had been in the Royal Engineers. The Daily Mail has basically created modernity. Yeah, exactly.
极其不适合以今天的标准来看——也就是《保罗·德拉蒙德》（Bulldog Drummond）系列小说，我们谈论过保罗·德拉蒙德，是的，他是詹姆斯·邦德的先驱。而在1922年，“莎帕”（Sapper）——他的真名叫H·C·麦克内尔（H.C. McNeile）。为了延续本期播客的一个主题，汤姆，他受到了鼓励为《每日邮报》写作。他曾服役于皇家工程兵部队。《每日邮报》基本上创造了现代性。对，没错。
So he writes these books about this guy called Captain Hugh Drummond, and he's a demobbed soldier. And like so many people, like so many of the people who joined, you know, Mussolini's black shirts or the Freikorps in Germany, he's come back from the war, Drummond, and he's bored. He doesn't know what to do, and he wants to fight people. And in this book, published second book in 1922, he sets up a group called the Black Gang,
所以他写了这些关于一个叫休·德拉蒙德（Hugh Drummond）上尉的书，他是一个退伍军人。和许多人一样，和那么多加入墨索里尼黑衫军或德国自由军团的人一样，德拉蒙德从战场回来后感到很无聊。他不知道该做些什么，他渴望找人打架。在这本于1922年出版的第二本书中，他成立了一个名为“黑帮”（Black Gang）的组织，
and they dress up in black cokes, very Ku Klux Klan and they go around beating up communists who are infiltrating Is this written in the consciousness of what Mussolini's doing? No, I think it, well, I suppose he probably must know to some, but I don't think I definitely don't think
他们穿着黑风衣，非常像三K党，到处殴打那些潜入……这难道是受墨索里尼行径的启发吗？不，我想它——好吧，我想他大概多少会知道一些，但我不认为——我绝对不认为
it's deliberately inspired but people sort of say, you know there's a point, I won't read out because i've been sending you quotes for the last few days utterly utterly unrepeatable but there's a point in which two people are talking about what's going on one of them says to the other um that there is an organized and well-financed conspiracy to preach bolshevism in england we have known for some time how well organized it is we did not realize but as you'll see there is not a single manufacturing town or city in great britain that has not got a branch of that organization installed he says you can see in front of you the proofs of their appalling spread
这是刻意模仿的，但人们会说，你知道的，有这样一段话——我不会全读出来，因为过去几天我一直在给你发那些完全无法重复的引用——但其中有一段话，两个人正在谈论发生的事情，其中一人对另有说道：“在英国，有一个有组织且资金雄厚的阴谋，在四处宣扬布尔什维克主义。我们很早就知道它的组织有多么严密。我们没有意识到的是，正如你将看到的，大不列颠没有一个制造城镇或城市里没有设立该组织的分支机构。”他说：“你眼前看到的，就是无产阶级主日学校骇人听闻的蔓延证据，它们散布可憎的宣传，公开企图将听课的儿童转化为一种宗教，其开端是毁灭，其结局是混乱的无政府状态。”
of these proletarian sunday schools with their abominable propaganda and their avowed attempt to convert the children who attend them to a creed whose beginning is destruction and whose end is chaotic anarchy but dominic aren't i right then that communism is just christianity monke well it's proliferating sunday schools but you know picking up that stuff we were saying about the spanish flu and viruses and the language of the wasteland that the same character then goes on to say we're a free country sir john but the time is coming when freedom as we understand it in the past will have to cease that's very fascistic we can't go on as the cesspit of europe sheltering microbes who infect us as soon as they are here we want disinfecting we want it
但是，多米尼克，我说的没错吧，共产主义其实就是基督教的杂种……好吧，它在激增主日学校，但正如我们之前谈到西班牙流感、病毒以及废土语言时所说的那样，同一个角色接着说道：“我们是一个自由的国家，约翰爵士，但时候快到了，过去我们所理解的那种自由将不得不戛然而止。”这非常具有法西斯色彩。“我们不能再做欧洲的下水道，庇护那些一到这里就感染我们的微生物了。我们需要消毒，我们需要彻底的消毒。”而这并不是在意大利或德国，这是在英国。这是一系列极其受欢迎、并在整个20年代被改编成电影的书籍。它们非常受欢迎，受众是那种中产阶级的、奉公守法的、具有强烈体面感的人。而1922年，
badly and this isn't italy or germany this is britain and this is a these are a series of books that are immensely popular and are made into films throughout the 1920s. They're immensely popular, kind of middle class, law-abiding, self-consciously respectable kind of people. And 1922
我认为，是英国殖民帝国在地理意义上达到最大疆域的一年。英国是一战的胜利者，所以这就是它的全盛时期，但正如我们将在第二部分中发现的那样，正如巴特·范·卢（Bart Van Loo）所说的那样，它在许多方面是一个泥足巨人。非常棒。好吧，多米尼克，我们会——我们会在明天发布另一期节目，内容将涵盖英国、爱尔兰、黎凡特和美国。
is, I think, the year when the British Empire is, geographically speaking, at its largest extent. Britain is the victor in the first world war so so that's the thing that it was um you know it's absolute peak but as we shall find out in part two it is in many ways a colossus with feet of clay as bart van loo would put it very good um so dominic we'll come we'll uh we'll do another episode, put that out tomorrow, and that will be on Britain, Ireland, the Levant, and America.
还有里奇蒙·克朗普顿（Richmond Crompton）。当然还有里奇蒙·克朗普顿。没错，就是《威廉姆斯》的主人公。好吧。非常感谢大家收听本期节目。我们明天见。再见。再见。再见。
And Richmond Crompton. And Richmond Crompton, of course. Yes, just William. Okay. So thanks very much for listening to this. We will see you tomorrow. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家剧集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册，网址是 rest is history pod dot... 本期节目尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restish history pod dot com that's rest is history pod dot There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。如需收听加长节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。